thanks to surfsharkvpn for helping
support this episode
stick around until the end for a special
offer hey crazies
most galaxies are moving away from us
over time
in fact the farther away they are the
faster they're moving away
if space is big enough some galaxies
should be moving away from us faster
than light
but how is that possible doesn't light
travel at the universal speed limit
[Music]
this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
all right let's establish two things
about light before we get into this
one light is actually pretty slow
astronomically speaking
i mean it seems pretty instantaneous to
us
we flip a switch and bam the room is
immediately filled with light
fast fast but that's only because rooms
aren't actually that big
it still seems fast even on the scale of
the earth
but you can begin to see it isn't
infinitely fast
light from the moon takes 1.3 seconds to
get here
light from the sun takes 8.3 minutes
wait is that even moving oh yep there it
is
anyway the alpha centauri system the
closest stars to the sun
are over four light years away that
means their light takes over
four years to get here light from the
andromeda galaxy
the closest spiral galaxy takes 2.5
million years the farther away the
source
the longer the time the cosmic microwave
background
or cmb has taken 13.8 billion years to
get here
that's billion with a b it's the oldest
light in the universe
the point is light takes time to get
places sometimes a long time
so in a way we shouldn't be that
surprised there's something going faster
two the speed of light isn't actually a
speed limit for all speeds
there are in fact plenty of things that
go faster
say we're outside one night and we
decide to point a laser at the moon
this is going to work we wouldn't be
able to see the laser thought
true but but this doesn't affect my main
point so assume we could see it
the dot would be pretty big by the time
it got there
even laser light spreads out if we start
on one edge of the moon and suddenly
move it to the opposite edge
the laser dot will move across the
surface of the moon faster than light
wait what for realsies
this isn't even a problem because the
speed of light isn't a universal speed
limit
it's just the speed limit of causality
of cause and effect
hear me out you know how you can get the
distance between things using
pythagorean theorem
a squared plus b squared equals c
squared well if you make time one of
those dimensions it still kind of works
this equation governs the order of cause
and effect
it's kind of a big deal all thanks to
pythagoras
pipithagoras whatever
this is the speed of light right here it
represents how quickly parts of space
can communicate across time the speed of
light isn't really about light
it's about causality about cause and
effect
if one event causes another everyone
agrees on the order of those events
the cause must come before the effect
with the laser on the moon it's
perfectly fine for the dot to move
faster than light
the events on either side of the moon
aren't causally connected
so there's no speed limit the cause is
all the way back on earth with the laser
the photons from the laser still can't
get to the moon faster than light
so there's a delay between you moving
the laser and the dot moving on the moon
as long as causality is maintained
things can go as fast as they want
and that's a rule that applies even in
cosmology
it's perfectly fine for distant galaxies
to be going faster than light
as long as they're not causing anything
faster than light
so thanks for liking it video from 2013
i answered the original question but how
did they get going that fast in the
first place
oh well that's a much deeper question
you've probably heard
something like this the faster you go
the more and more kinetic energy you
need to keep going faster
you would need an infinite amount of
energy to accelerate to the speed of
light
right so how can distant galaxies break
that rule that simple rule
is a special case which is why we call
the model special relativity
is there a general case yep it's called
general relativity
and it's absolutely necessary for
cosmology
let's get back to this causality
equation from earlier
it isn't quite enough in fact
in general relativity what it looks like
depends on the circumstances
and it can get pretty complicated
sometimes this
is what it looks like near a rotating
black hole yikes
thankfully on cosmological scales the
universe is extremely uniform and simple
we only need to take our special case
and smash an extra factor in there
it's called the scale factor it
represents the scale of space
as space expands the scale factor gets
bigger
that's the reason distant galaxies can
move faster than light
they're just carried along as space
expanse
the distance where galaxies are
expanding away at exactly the speed of
light
is called the whole horizon
it's 14.5 billion light years away which
is about 14.4 billion farther than our
brains could ever hope to comprehend
but that's not even the most surprising
bit about this
you might expect the hubble horizon to
be the limit of our vision
but it isn't we can actually see past it
there are two more horizons beyond it
one is our vision limit of the present
the other
is our vision limit of the past that
last one
is three times farther than the hubble
horizon
if you want to learn more about those
horizons i have a video on them but
let's get back to the expansion of space
this time right here
is not the time measured by the earth
it's what we call the cosmic time
it's the time measured by someone who
isn't moving relative to the source of
the cmb you know
this stuff this is just a map though it
gives you the wrong impression
the cmb is actually the inside surface
of a sphere
in its raw form it's red shifted in one
direction
and blue shifted in the other that tells
us the earth is moving relative to
whatever stuff is emitting this light
which isn't the most convenient point of
view for cosmology
if we adjust the cmb data to remove that
color shift
then we have a better point of view we
call this
the co-moving frame oh yeah we're going
there
what is it co-moving with the expansion
let's say we're dealing with a bunch of
events across space that all happen at
the same cosmic time
our new version of causality simplifies
to this
we already know a is the scale factor
the thing that grows when space expands
the other two things are different
measures of distance proper distance
and co-moving distance proper distance
is called proper because it's the kind
of distance we're used to
you take space slap down a static grid
and you're good to go
as space expands galaxies and everything
inside them
are taken along for the ride the proper
distance between galaxies increases
this is the distance we actually see
when we look out into the universe
but the co-moving distance is actually
much more convenient in cosmology
it's called co-moving because it
co-moves with the expansion
as space expands the grid goes with it
distant galaxies
remain roughly the same co-moving
distance from each other
as time passes this coordinate doesn't
change with the expansion
the scale factor does that gives people
the impression that galaxies can't move
and co-moving towards
us and they can hmm i i suppose you're
right
as two galactic clusters expand away
from each other with the grid
the galaxies inside those clusters can
also move around locally
a little bit both of these can change
it's just that a change in the scale
factor represents the expansion
and the change in the co-moving
coordinate represents actual
local motion and that's the loophole
that distant galaxies exploit to go
faster than light
since both of these can change there are
actually two different velocities
a recession velocity because it measures
things receding from us
and a peculiar velocity because i don't
know why it's called that
don't get on my case okay i don't get to
name these things
anyway the the recession velocity is the
one that's bigger than the speed of
light
the peculiar velocity is the one that
must be slower
why though because causality
remember this all started with causality
with the order of cause and effect
the speed of light isn't the upper limit
on how fast things can move
it's the upper limit on how fast two
points in space can communicate with
each other
only the peculiar velocity lets parts of
space communicate
so only that velocity has the speed of
light limit
i should also point out here that
recession velocity isn't
really a velocity at least not in the
way that we usually understand it
it's not actually a change in distance
over time it's a change in scale over
time
it's the scale factor that changes not
the coordinate
the recession velocity is kind of an
illusion created by the expansion of
space
the rate of expansion isn't even
measured as a speed it's measured as a
speed
over a distance it's about 70 kilometers
per second
per megaparsec also known as the hubble
parameter
that just means galaxies are moving away
at 70 kilometers per second
for every megaparsec they are distant
the more space there is to expand
between us
the faster they'll seem like they're
moving away in fact the difference
between these two speeds
actually explains the difference between
two types of redshift
doppler redshift and cosmological
redshift
i realize someone who would go unnamed
just released a video
explaining how all the redshifts are the
same i disagree
while i'm comfortable saying the doppler
redshift and gravitational redshift are
the same
cosmological redshift is entirely its
own beast
these two different velocities result in
two different redshifts
the second one gives us doppler redshift
because it's an
actual velocity the first one gives us
cosmological redshift
the redshift caused by the expansion of
space
it's not actually a velocity though so
it can't be the same as doppler
it just can't seriously if you graph out
doppler and cosmological redshift
against velocity
the patterns are approximately true for
small redshifts
but they diverge wildly for large
redshifts
doppler redshift maxes out at the speed
of light
cosmological redshift does not they're
not the same
they're just not are you okay
yeah i think i got it out of my system
sorry
i i haven't ranted on camera in a while
anyway
to summarize distant galaxies can go
faster than light by
cheating when measuring how far away
distant objects are
there are two factors that matter the
scale factor
and the co-moving coordinate they create
a grid that grows with the expansion of
space
as a result there are two different
types of motion taking place
only one of those motions has a speed
limit though the speed of light is
only the limit on cause and effect not
on everything it's the maximum speed
that two different points in space can
communicate
only this velocity lets parts of space
communicate
so it's the only one with a speed limit
it's a limit we just can't
break but there are communication limits
we can break
with a vpn like surf shark you've
probably heard of vpns before but there
are two
real reasons you might want one one not
all locations are created equal did you
know that different streaming services
offer different content in different
countries maybe you live in the us
but want to watch something only offered
in the uk all you've got to do is say
you're in the uk on surf shark and bam
you get to watch it a single
subscription allows you to use surfshark
on an unlimited number of devices
simultaneously
two you're super paranoid maybe you
don't like that your isp can throttle
you based on the websites you visit
maybe you don't want your university's
central server to know what you're
looking at
maybe you need to bypass some government
censorship i'm not judging
if the vpn channel drops out
unexpectedly
surfshark can automatically disconnect
your internet to protect you
they also have a strict no logs policy
so they're not keeping a record of your
activity either
no matter what you're hiding or who
you're hiding it from
surfsharkvpn can help if you're
interested go to the link in the
description below and enter the promo
code asylum
you'll get 84 off and four extra months
for free
which is a good deal it'll also let surf
shark know you heard about them from me
which helps out the channel so got any
questions about cosmology
please ask in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember
it's okay to be a little crazy
i know many of you were expecting part
two of the wife reacts video
it's just that this video has been on
the schedule for a while it had to
happen
wife reacts part two is next probably
and thanks for watching
you